hunderte nilpferde beim baden und ihr
seht es bereits wieder eingeblendet es
geht heute mal wieder um google maps
genau und zwar um das mounten medio
christian center da beten wir heute in
der stunde lang meine lieben freunde
darum geht es natürlich nicht heute
sondern wir reisen mal wieder ein wenig
rum hier in google maps beispielsweise
hier in die stadt neuss da leben
definitiv keine frauen
wir können ja unser kleines männchen
hinnehmen und können das einfach mal
irgendwo hier drauf setzt das ist schon
krass
er guckt euch das mal an das ist ja
alles wie ein schachbrett gebaut wir
können hier in der stadt wo es einfach
mal ein bisschen rumlaufen können uns
ein bisschen umschauen unser
da
das ist eine frau
raus aus beuys mit dir nein spass
freunde hat natürlich nichts gegen
frauen hier kann jeder an boyles leben
wie er will man wieder lustig ist wir
befinden uns hier allerdings gar nicht
um uns anzuschauen sondern wir sind hier
bewege wir reden muss auch gelernt sein
wir sind hier wegen diesem kleinen ort
hier freuen und zwar wenn wir noch näher
heran zoomen sieht man schon jesus loves
you
und es gibt sogar ein foto von na ja
genau das genauso sieht das aus also
wirklich mithin in amerika wirklich
zentral mitten drin ich weiß nicht was
der bundesstraße start ist oder dass ich
sogar schon ein bisschen westküste es
ist in ida hoch daher kenne ich gar
nicht mitten hier am fuße sonnebergs
kette ist einfache dieses sein wo jemand
dieses live stream mit dem rasenmäher in
seinen rasen gemäht hat also ich meine
wir sonst nichts zu tun hat da kann man
das ganze natürlich machen allerdings
geht es heute nicht nur um dieses jesus
loves you stylen sondern ich habe noch
einige mehr ort herausgesucht haben dass
ihr beispielsweise ist auch in amerika
ihr merkt schon diese folge wird nicht
so wie meine letzte folge google maps
dann wird klar eine frau vom auto
überfahren ja in meiner letzten folge
gehe ich mit street view bisschen durch
rumgelaufen paar komische sachen
entdeckt helfen ältere mutter dieses
google maps video haben wir halt
unfassbar viele leute die kommentare
geschrieben harry luca guck dir mal den
ort an den ort den rogers von alles orte
die man nicht durch street view sehen
kann sondern 0 für diese obendrauf sicht
also es gibt ja mehrere versionen bei
google maps gibt ja dieses von oben
gucken und mit 7 laufen wenn wir das
hier ist unser nächster ort dann einfach
[ __ ] you auf sein dach geschrieben so
dass das leute die vielleicht mit einem
flugzeug bei der niedrigen höhe darüber
fliegen dass sie das hier lesen können
oder halt solche google maps vollidioten
wie ich die laufen dann ihr lang denken
sich nichts böses denkt ein schöner tag
a [ __ ] you
ja also ich glaube ihr seht schon worum
es im heutigen video geht freunde mir
wurden wirklich so unfassbar viele
verschiedene lustige verrückte
interessante furchteinflößende orte in
die kommentare geschrieben
da muss ich hin ich habe auch sehr viele
kommentare bekommen von wegen luca schau
dir mal tokio an das wollte ich
allerdings in meinem nächsten google
maps video machen wollt ihr überhaupt
dass ich nochmal so komisch rumlaufe wie
ich das in rom gemacht habe
einfach mal nur ein oberkörper habe an
meine damen und herren lasst die jetzt
bei diesem video hier 30.000 likes dar
es ist eine menge 30 30.000
30.000 leute das ist eine menge bei
30.000 likes werde ich in ein zwei
wochen auf jeden fall noch mal einen
teil google maps hochladen wo ich
wirklich street view mäßig durch die
straßen laufen jobs macht sondern
vielleicht in tokio mich aufhalten
werden allerdings soll es heute nicht um
tokio gehen und auch nicht nur in
amerika sondern auch um einen anderen
ort der leider auch in amerika ist eine
menge amerika der ort heißt dixon
tatsächlich und der name ist hier
tatsächlich programm meine damen und
herren also wir sehen schon dixon ist
eine sehr schöne stadt wir sehen hier
vorne so einen kleinen wasserfall oder
zumindest das ist hier ein bisschen
runter geht dann haben wir vorne den
dicksten park wir haben verschiedene
sachen und wir haben auch das hier das
ist tatsächlich wenn man das mal ein
bisschen dreht so wie ich das jetzt
gerade für euch gemacht habe das ist
eine dicke in dixon
ich wette
in dieser stadt kann man gut
ja genau baby darum kaufen hab ich
gerade gesagt na ja sehr interessant auf
jeden fall dass ich diese person bei
diesem gebäude hier gedacht hat ich weiß
gar nicht ob es überhaupt absichtlich
gemacht hat
es sieht ja aus wie
ja doch oder von der seite gucke also
ein ganz mysteriöses gebäude hier meine
damen und herren es ähnelt sehr dem
geschlechtsteil des mannes in der stadt
nichts und tatsächlich aber kommen wir
nun zu einem komischen wald hat da das
heißt tatsächlich der guitar park das
ist hier ein park mitten in argentinien
also wirklich um der internet so mitten
in argentinien mitten in der pampa wenn
ich noch ganz weit raus -rufe seht ihr
weg mitten am arsch in argentinien
mithin mitten am arsch ist diese gitarre
ich weiß nicht was die person geritten
hat die dass dinge gepflanzt hat also da
scheint ja kein rotkohl zu sein sondern
irgendwelche lila denn bäume oder so
hier fordert der seite wahrscheinlich
seine hütte im jahr drei silos und
dieser in einer reinen kakteen hier vorn
hat den kreisverkehr also dem
baseball-schläger komische dinge auf
jeden fall ihr vor die pflanze sein
marihuana an mir hat der sonnen
sonnenstern das soll wahrscheinlich ist
das ding in der gitarre sein ich hätte
damit jetzt nicht so gut ausgeht da habe
ich nie gespielt klavier ganz lang
klavier super super klasse gitarre bini
zuge kommen hätte ich aber mal bock
drauf ich versuche mich auch selber so
ein bisschen was musik angeht ein
bisschen weiter zu entwickeln ich werde
nie singen
keine sorge keine sorge luca wird nicht
singen produzieren beats machen gucke
für andere leute die das ding das schon
eher mein ding aber da werde demnächst
mal was sehen allerdings ist das hier
halt das nächste was ich bei google maps
rausgesucht habe also das ist wirklich
eine gitarre mitten im nirgendwo krass
der kita sind derart zwei berichte fünf
sterbe
wow dass da überhaupt einer hin fährt
mitten im nirgendwo
hier mittel
mitten ich habe
ich hab verloren
wir haben die gitarre verloren
ist aber auch egal meine damen und
herren ich würde sagen machen direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten ort und es war
kämpferisch eine sehr bekannte
universitätsstadt mitten in england er
mir sehen hier senioren sitzen an dieser
kleinen umflut hier genießen das leben
direkt neben dem mülheimer und dann
fragt sich erstmal hey was ist denn hier
falsch strand also falsch an dem bild
ist gar nichts zu fordern ist irgendwie
ein baum abgeknickt oder so zu
blockieren verleiht warum ist eine
brücke
über sonnen himmel ding hier
das sind 10 cm
wahrscheinlich günstiger gewesen einfach
ein bisschen erde hin zu packen aber gut
die engländer sind eben bisschen komisch
aber es geht hier allerdings um kühe die
kuh die genießt ihr leben ihr vorne die
andere auch die schilder auch bisschen
ist und die hat ihr gesicht zensiert ja
da hat sich die courage einig einfach
gedacht oh that's my face on google maps
ein iq jura und dann wurde das gesicht
zensiert also anders kann ich mir das
nicht erklären die anderen kühe hier die
haben alle gesichter nenne hier vorne
hier rum starb durch die scheiße die
hier fordert die sich in einem baum
versteckt die fette dicke hier da hinten
die vierte dicke wahrscheinlich und
diese kurt einfach kein gesicht also
wenn du hast du eine menge fliegen auf
dem rücken die gut tut mir auf jeden
fall leidige sicht war leider nicht
schön genug von google maps wir befinden
uns allerdings direkt schon wieder in
tokio das liebe ich ja so an google maps
auch dass man einfach wirklich sagen
kann ich bin in tokio beim ich bin auf
dem mond okay das gab jetzt vielleicht
doch nicht so aber dass man wirklich von
einem schnitzer zum anderen einfach so
tausende kilometer reisen kann und
beispielsweise auch zu einfach eine
menge leuten bin da tauben mit einer
tauben
was ist falsch mit den leuten neiße
slippers bei baker ist jetzt wirklich
mitten in tokio einfach in irgendeine
straße standen so leute mit so einem
tauben masken haben das lustiges hier
stehen sogar so leute mit kameras et
cetera pp der ist da gerade ein paar
pommes oder so das lustige ist da wir
jetzt an dem pitch uns vorbeigelaufen
sind an dieser petition gegen sage ich
mal an der tauben gang an die gucken
sich alle zu dumm um darauf an dass
google maps enthält so viele verrückte
sachen irgendein satellit hier hat
beispielsweise tokio aufgenommen und
befindet sich hier oben
das ist unfassbar kummer wir spinnen
einfach rum und können hier hinreisen
nicht ob das jetzt afrika ein paar
sekunden später
ja sind wir sind
wir sind einfach in der wüste aber ich
finde das mega krass man kann wirklich
überall hin reise unter anderem auch zur
daily
ach okay da gibt es mehrere suchbegriffe
beziehungsweise suchergebnisse freund
ich meinen allerdings dass sie vorne
dagegen rallye die fans werden schon
wissen das ist die winkelgasse in harry
potter und zwar sind dass hier die
warner studios wir können einfach mal
hier unser mennicken hinsetzen und sehen
schon da
der forspeed drive ist glaube ich nicht
genau hier als harry aufgewachsen bei
den barclays dass jetzt die brücke die
auch halo besitzt ein bisschen
verschwammen aus das ist die brücke die
bei hogwarts war das hier ist glaube ich
das gebäude in dem ich weiß was da war
da waren die in einem der letzten teile
dieser frau die aber nur ein
verkleideter todesser war ich weiß es
nicht ganz genau freunde dass wir sind
auf jeden fall die warner studios wo ein
großer teil der harry potter filme
gedreht wurde wir können uns einfach mal
hier absetzen und dann sehen wir schon
wir befinden uns in noch nicht der
winkelgasse allerdings hier meine damen
und herren das hier ist die alte gut
bekannte winkelgasse ich weiß nicht ich
bin riesiger harry-potter-fan dagegen ja
auch die meinungen auseinander
hier am see die bank gringotts wie vor
die wände wo alle ihre zauberstäbe her
hatten haben wir vorne den laden denen
die brüder von ron hatten als es im
letzten teil so zu ende gingen mit
voldemort und so also mega mega krasser
sie sind auf jeden fall die warner
studios hier vorne mit denen wirklich
viele dinge die in den harry potter film
vorgekommen sind gedreht wurde
allerdings kommen wir auch nun schon zum
letzten ort freunde ihr seht ihr schon
was ist das hier wieder für eine kacke
das ist einfach ein campingplatz heißt i
kuju public wahrscheinlich wieder mitten
in amerika irgendwo man denkt sich
erstmal haye
duca
was ist das
immer mal ran
nilpferde
hunderte nilpferde beim baden
ich sag euch eine google maps es ist es
ist so krass an der stelle würde ich
mein heutiges video ist allerdings auch
beenden meine damen und herren wendet
euch genauso viel spaß gemacht haben wie
mir dann würde ich mich unglaublich soll
über einen like freuen
wie gesagt wollt ihr dass ich in meiner
nächsten folge google maps nach tokio
reise 30.000 likes wenn ihr da bock
drauf habt mich würd's mega mega freuen
dort man hin zu reisen ich feiere tokio
mich reizt echtermann hinzufliegen
schreibt mir allerdings gerne auch
andere städte und in die kommentare wo
ihr meint ja auch luca du musst auf
jeden fall mal nach herzogenaurach
kommen du musst du mal hamburg anschauen
elbphilharmonie mit viola du musst mal
nach timbuktu mega da schreibt mir alles
in die kommentare spread alles zu mit
städten wo ich hin soll
und ja ich bin da man jetzt mal mit
nilpferden baden
[Musik]
zum 1